il
elle a loué saint gilles dans l'ouest de
l'île comme plusieurs fois par semaine
on a bien un rendez vous chez ses
clientes travailleuses indépendantes
elle propose des prestations de
tatouages temporaires aux aînés le henné
est un arbuste épineux de la famille
délit tracé pouvant atteindre jusqu'à
six mètres de haut
ses feuilles réduite en poudre contient
une molécule particulière dit là où
sonne du nom scientifique de l'arbuste
elles produisent des teintes rouges
jaunes et orangés utilisé en teinture
textile et corporelle coloration et
entretien des cheveux tatouages
éphémères de la peau aussi dit arcus
donc ce sont les feuilles qu'on mélange
donc on les transforme en poudre on y
mixe bien et ont mis un peu d'eau et un
peu de sucre et après il faut que le
mélange soit homogène puis après on peut
soit le maître sur la peau soit après
certaines personnes collant les cheveux
également avec que valable comme c'est
naturel n'y a pas de produits chimiques
c'est nourrissant ça fait du bien c'est
bon pour la peau pour les cheveux russie
le mot est née désigne également ce
colorant dont l'usagé très anciens
puisqu'on en retrouve la trace dans les
momies égyptiennes
il serait originaire du sud de l'iran et
de la mésopotamie il aurait été
introduit en egypte sous la vingtième
dynastie
le henné est utilisé à de multiples fins
cosmétiques et ul de mariage
dermatologiques teintures capillaires
parfumerie ou encore thérapeutique
c'était une culture
d'origine musulmane donc les femmes pour
s'embellir en fait parce qu'à l'époque
avait pas de maquillage avait pas de
produits esthétiques donc à
s'embellissent et donc leur corps les
mains les pieds avec les tatouages
éphémères donc qui faisait chez eux en
fait avec cette pâte d'origine naturelle
dont qui coûte rien parce qu'ils
allaient récolter et préparer tout ça ne
peut pas passer à côté surtout dans les
moments festifs en fait parce que par
exemple fiançailles mariages les
grossesses
c'est un rituel on passe pas à côté
attention tout de même car sur certaines
personnes l'application d'huisne et peut
provoquer de graves allergies
mais c'est surtout le cas du henné noir
comme tout rituel où tradition les
pratiques évoluent avec le temps est au
contact du monde qui nous entoure
ainsi le tatouage éphémère où est né à
dépasser le cadre de la tradition dans
les pays occidentaux
si les tendances les faux tatouages
surtout ce sont les célébrités qui l'ont
lancé c'est on va dire c'est comme un
essai avant de faire un vrai tatouage
est allé demande de plus en plus au
niveau des tatouages maoris justement
polynésien est un peu de tri mal aussi
et sinon c'est en l'indien les symboles
chinois également souvent c'est avant de
faire un vrai en cas de changement bon
c'est sûr créé à partir et ça dure 15
jours à peu près quand même mais le
partage le contact et l'évolution c'est
aussi ce qui fait vivre une culture et
une tradition que grâce au côté moderne
il est encore là parce que si personne
ne s'intéresse aux anciens dessins et
aux anciens motifs et que dans la
nouveauté non qu il n'y a pas à
disparaître' est carrément là je sais
qu'à travers justement ce phénomène de
mode et à travers les effets avant
tatouage il est encore là il encore
présent donc je pense qu'il va encore
survivre
fst